I'll help of everybody check that out
and two tickets class I'm hopeful verse
with kalila dr. B this is from Megan I
am 20 years old African American a
graphic designer in Central Texas I work
in a quiet office with all white people
they are very southern and very nice but
I have a small problem whenever they
talk to me they turn into in quotations
urban Bobby they put on a hood voice and
drop their g's after their it might be
speaking my language I don't even speak
like that I speak like a normal southern
person with almost no accent what should
I do
it's a difficult one because as an Asian
you get it oh as an Asian you for sure
gay people come up to me after my shows
like if I'm in the South white people
and they go oh we already warned you
they smile and then they go and they go
and that gets a laugh at work whatever
in their head right that's how they act
like you know right I was dead on right
and then you kind of go they don't know
any better so you just gotta go hahaha
that's good but it's bothersome it
irritates me but I never get angry
because they're just doing the best they
can I mean these are the kind of people
that are voting from Trump they don't
know any better I won't say they're all
voting for Trump I think that people's
just think they're looking for like a
relatability sometimes and they do it
the wrong way
yeah so I I think maybe your co-workers
are thinking that they're trying to be
funny and cute with you
but it is so I am it's so cringe-worthy
I'm sorry like I I get why imagine
having to go okay you don't like when
people do that to you after your shows
right this person has to work with
people like that every day in a
workplace yeah but I experience every
day at work I mean you go to clubs you
know I mean and you know comics will
come up and go hiya or whatever they
might do and you just kind of go okay
it's they're just slightly funny you're
saying let it slide then don't tell
these people like hey like why are you
dropping your G's well the way you do
that
is not respond so it's like for instance
let's say I do a show and you're a white
dude come and do an accent to me hi papi
I love the show so that you know
anything it's uncomfortable then they
then they'll go into like defense mode
I'm sorry yeah I just do that I have a
lot of Asian friends or whatever Oh God
oh the worst is when they go um hey I
went to call it a college with a guy
who's Korean like you're supposed to go
oh no you're my best friend no way
that's what they do to me to you as soon
as I tell them I'm Filipino oh I love
punch sit and lumpia like that's the
only like like it's it's okay cool
awesome I've never done dad to it doctor
I'd never been that through arm anybody
in my life I don't think like to walk
talk to a black eye yeah I have a friend
that's black I mean why would I do that
it's so weird he walked that though
that'd be so weird if you want but I I
do think it's not coming from a bad
place that's why I never say I like you
I don't really say anything I just kind
of engaged and I'm like oh you'd like
bunts it and they'll be cool like good
for you I don't know I think we should
not respond just Doom's we're just
you're just it's more energy to be
hostile that's not being hostile
I just how about this you said to me I'm
gonna smile on your face but not say
anything go ahead
hey Bobby I love I hate girls honey
Buffy's not doing anything right no
what's better this I said that that one
makes it more uncomfortable like he's
finally one no no the other one yeah
it's like I [ __ ] up I'm sorry I'm so
sorry that was like why don't you do a
smile with that uncomfortable that yeah
I love limpia and malignant Allah oh I
love
oh really really
that's what you do my african-american
friend at work do that Megan nice good
for you
[Music]